several memorials across the valley
honor the lives of those cyclists 8 news
now reporter Joshua peguero tells us how
leaders are now spearheading another
this is around the area where the Red
Rock Legacy Trail would start and one
Clark County Commissioner is pushing to
have a memorial remembering the five
cyclists who died in December of 2020
but I know for the families of the
victims the the memories are never going
to fade
and so I just want to you know obviously
send my regards out over the past two
years Clark County Commissioner Justin
Jones says Clark County has made efforts
to address biker safety they've added
buffers and protected bike Lanes along
with new trails construction will start
in the parking lot for the Red Rock
Legacy Trail in about 18 months in every
decision that we make we're thinking
about cyclist safety pedestrian safety
making sure that safety is of primary
concern there is a memorial already
erected for the five victims the bicycle
shop Las Vegas Cyclery also created its
own prior to this incident to highlight
cyclist deaths this one just is just to
remind find people that you know
cyclists are out there and to be careful
and to you know watch the road general
manager Sean Tyrone no longer rides his
bike on the roads I don't feel safe
anymore and I've ridden in this town for
30 plus years
and I've just kind of watched the the
traffic increase the distractions
increase and the deaths increase the 5.5
Mile Trail would end at the Red Rock
Canyon fee station and it would also be
open to pedestrians reporting near
Charleston Boulevard and Sky Vista Drive
Joshua peguero eight news now